so hello everybody i'm really excited to
be back with richard roland for our
third discussion
on mythical history on this universal
history
for this episode we're going to dive
into ethiopia and i'm really excited
about this because i
have been a a big fan of just this
mystery of ethiopia i traveled to
ethiopia and i've just been
fascinated with how its role is not just
in the bible but in other ancient
cultures as well and so i'm really
looking forward
to exploring this with him
yeah i'm i'm very excited about this
conversation i have been
actually since i was a little kid we had
this
this textbook i think it might have been
like a middle school textbook or
something like this but
um there was a single paragraph in this
world history textbook a single
paragraph
you know probably three to four
sentences that mentioned
the once great christian kingdom of
aksum
in northern africa and then basically
said but it was
wiped out by islam and there are no more
christians there anymore
and this isn't a this isn't a textbook
um
it's actually a fairly well known
history textbook i won't say which one
but
um and so i i i sort of as a kid like i
had this romantic idea in my head
and then of course many years later
discovered actually you know there are
still christians
in that part of the world and you know
now i've actually been able to meet a
few
um archbishop uh dimitri who's the the
sainted founder
of the the diocese that i'm in uh he was
very uh he had a very loving
relationship with the ethiopian and
eritrean communities
here in the dallas fort worth metroplex
and so we actually have some
you know eritrean folks who are are
actually you know we're received into
our parish and are
members of our parish um and they they
you know once a year
we do uh right right before lent we do
this big eritrean meal
um and uh but there's also
uh there's also you know i've just had
random encounters with ethiopian and
eritrean christians like
like very strange very wonderful
encounters like i don't want to use up
all of our time to talk about them but
both both here in the dallas fort fort
worth metroplex but actually most often
when i travel
i always seem to run into these
ethiopian orthodox christians
um and you know so it's i i've just got
a really deep love for the culture
and obviously there's some really cool
things that ethiopian christianity seems
to
preserve for us uh stuff like the book
of enoch for instance the only full
copies that we have of those of those
enoki and manuscripts are all
from ethiopia uh so i think that
if if somebody wanted to know why would
we want to talk about ethiopia
i'd say first of all it's because
ethiopia is a very interesting proof
case
right when we're talking about universal
history and why it's still important to
us
if you can understand the place of
ethiopia in the scriptures and in the
medieval universal history
then that will actually tell you
something about the importance of
ethiopia today
and then so it's a good way to show how
the the legends of a people their sort
of symbolic identity
uh participates in the larger universal
narrative and then ultimately
i think maybe that helps us understand
the ways
that uh ethiopia might be i'm going to
be careful here because i don't sound
like i'm trying to make prophecies or
something like that but
the role that ethiopia still seems to
have to play
in in the christian story the big story
yeah which is of course ongoing right
yeah um so i thought what we could do is
start out by
talking about ethiopia in scripture and
that would probably bring us
up all the way to the queen of sheba and
the ethiopian eunuch
which are two things that actually you
have to understand together to
understand
them at all and that's probably as far
as we're going to be able to get
in a single video but maybe we can just
sort of tease
ethiopia in medieval universal history
and how that relates to alexander
yeah definitely i think that we might be
doing a few episodes on
ethiopia at some point because it i
think in terms of
a role like you said going to ethiopia i
was in ethiopia for a few weeks and
it's you can see that it's a place that
still is full of magic that there really
are possibilities that exist there right
that seemed to be completely evacuated
from the rest of the world
i was on lake tana where all these
monasteries are these like
round monasteries which are amazing and
i'm on the lake and i'm going towards
the the monasteries and i'm looking at
this lake and it's something it's like
out of a fairy tale
and the guide was like this rasta guy
obviously not like a very
if he was a christian he's obviously not
extremely uh you know he was just a
guide right and i looked at him and i
looked at the lake and i said
are they is there a monster in this lake
and he like he hesitated he didn't want
to really answer
because he didn't like the question i
guess and he kind of looked at me and he
goes yeah
and he says it's a monster that will
will
take its victims we'll pull it down into
the water for six days and release them
on the sabbath and i was like
[Laughter]
i just couldn't believe it i was like
it's amazing of course it was non-stop
like all my time you need to have it
non-stop these like ins
like just amazing stories that i was
that i was getting from what else what
else would there
be in that way exactly it's like how how
could there be anything else in this
yeah
all right well okay so let's let's begin
with with ethiopian scripture here
because
i we might come back to that late thing
here in a little bit
um so the first reference that we have
to the land of and i'll say in the old
testament in the hebrew old testament
the word is usually kush
um ethiopia is a greek word uh it first
appears in homer
um so some some translations of the of
the
bible like the king james use ethiopia
and then maybe more recent translations
will say the land of cush but it's
talking about that same area the area
that's kind of on the horn of africa
there
so the first reference that we get to
this is in the four rivers that flow out
of eden and of course you've done some
great videos on
what are the rivers and what do they
what are they doing symbolically and all
the stuff
uh edie and eden's not a terrestrial
location
uh in the sen you know in this way but
uh so
we're told that this name of the second
river is the gihon
it is the one that flowed around the
whole land of kush or the whole land of
ethiopia
now nobody totally agrees on
uh exactly which river the gihon is
the ethiopians themselves associate it
with the abe
river which is the blue nile so it's one
of the two major tributary rivers that
flows into the nile
what's really interesting is that a lot
of arab authors actually try to identify
it
as of being a river that's in or around
the hindu kush
now this might seem very contradictory
obviously these are two very divergent
locations separated by thousands of
miles
which you have to understand though is
that india and ethiopia are very
closely related in ancient let's say
ancient geography or ancient cosmology
so homer who is the first person to
mention the ethiopians as a people
writes that they are be that they are to
be found at the extreme
east which is in india and the extreme
west which is northern africa of the
greek world
so uh they're divided by the sea into
the eastern so so the idea is it's the
land that the sun touches
right so that the land of the extreme
east which is india right the sun rises
in the east and the extreme west where
it goes down yeah so it's understanding
them as
the place of extreme like they are they
are the people that live on the extremes
exactly uh so later writers of of
late antiquity and even the early middle
ages for instance there's a latin
account i want to say it's maybe 7th or
8th century
there's a latin account of the
conversion of the ethiopians that
actually calls them indians it conflates
india and ethiopia this is a very
natural thing to do
one useful way to kind of understand the
relationship in
economic terms which is the most boring
way to understand anything but
maybe it'll help some people is that
there is
the major trade route in the ancient
world for goods especially spices coming
from
uh india was that they was the that
trade route passed through the horn of
africa so anything
for anything to enter the roman world
from india
it almost always came through the horn
of africa through ethiopia so
you can see you can see kind of the
relationship there so
uh so ethiopia or kush it's it's a it's
a it's a complex geographical term in
ancient literature
because it can refer to like the ancient
regions of aksum
of nubia it can be more generally used
for anything in sub-saharan africa right
yeah um
so this phrase um and there's a phrase
that appears over and over again
in biblical literature and also
elsewhere in the ancient world beyond
the rivers of ethiopia or beyond the
rivers of cush
right so basically it's it and this
shows up in prophetic literature it also
shows up in like you know talking about
in the book of esther when it talks
about the
the empire of artaxerxes right that he
ruled from
such and such a location to beyond the
rivers of ethiopia in other words to the
end of the world
so it refers to this the extreme end of
something originally both
east and west the extreme end of the
known world
yeah that's exactly the and if we're
talking about mythical history and we're
talking about right
the role that a people or or a nation or
an identity plays in the
not only like in the spatial
understanding of how the world lays
itself out but also in the story
then we we have to we don't have to get
hung up too much
on where exactly the ancients thought it
was
right you know on the map but rather
understand what role it played for them
in the way that the way that they talked
about it
so the ethiopians if we look at the
table of nations for instance in genesis
chapter 10 the ethiopians are or the
cushites are descendants this are you
know come from
the sons of noah and they come come from
ham in this case
um and it it's it's interesting to point
out here that
there was definitely a let's say a
species of american christianity here in
the south
um even until quite recently that
basically
you know identified you know black
people as because they're the son of
you know the the descendants of of ham
that they they they have this curse on
them
you know and it was it was actually one
of the uh one of the arguments used to
justify slavery
yeah and the the thing to kind of
understand about that is that these
people
you know as as jesus would say you do
not know either the scriptures or the
power of god like if you if
if you if you're reading genesis and you
come away with that
take on this then then like you haven't
read to the end of the story right
exactly you don't you're just like not
getting it yeah
how it plays out yeah you don't
understand the pattern so
um so according to the book of aksum
which is uh it's a late collection of
texts that's based on
basically a collection of a bunch of
much much earlier oral traditions
the etymology of the name ethiopia
ethiopia has
three potential etymologies and i think
you can understand these as all
revealing
something different about the the
pattern of
what ethiopia represents symbolically
obviously the most common one the one
that the greeks assigned was that it
just meant
like burnt face or red brown um
but scholars today think that ethiopia
might have come from um an egyptian word
which means the stealer of the heart
the steeler of hearts so yeah and
bracket that we're going to come back to
that in a minute
uh cause that's really interesting um
but in the book of aksum they derive
ethiopia from the name
of ethiopies uh who is a he's he's an
extra biblical son of the biblical kush
so he comes from the city founding line
remember it's cain
you know that built who builds the first
city so this is the book of aksum is it
a this is an ethiopian source yeah yeah
it's a it's a it's their
it's their sort of collection actually
there's a bunch of legal texts there's a
bunch of animals
it's just like a collection of like
their older tradition
that sort of codified at a certain point
in the middle ages but it's much older
stuff
um so they had they actually had a an
extra biblical son of kush who they
believed
came to this part of africa and
built a city he's believed to have built
the city of uh i think it's said
mazeeber or i'm probably saying that
wrong but anyway
that's the original capital of the
kingdom of aksum
so note that he comes from the city
founding line of cain
but then he goes beyond the place where
cain
and his descendants founded their
civilization in the fertile crescent
uh so he goes on to found his own city
it's kind of a city on the edge of the
world
yeah and it's important to understand
like this is where
it becomes important to understand the
manner in which
the a people self-identify right so the
ethiopians themselves see them
they see themselves as descendants of
kush and
and it's and it's important to it's
important to see that like they see
themselves in a certain
line and so when we talk about how other
nations understood them we look at how
they understood themselves
and it's interesting sometimes to see
how these these things actually come
together so there's a
there's a negative and positive aspect
to whatever
dissent whatever descendants you take
like any symbolic pattern
the northern people like the northern
people understood their own
their own challenges and so they saw
themselves some of them saw themselves a
bastard son
like oh not a bastard zone but this like
weird son that was born on the ark and
was not completely
accounted for let's say and so in the
same with ethiopians that
that we need to understand all these
stories to see
the positive and negative side of the
role that they
played or that they can play in this
giant cosmic story right
and of course as you know even today
ethiopia is famous
for having churches monasteries and
settlements in these really extreme
locations
i mean you can just go like look online
look at at documentaries or
pictures on google of of these
monasteries that are in these totally
inaccessible
you know craggy mountaintops um
there's actually a place called the
finca hebera site
i think it's finca or fincha herberasite
this is in the bail mountains
of ethiopia and they found remains
of a really ancient human settlement
like a really long-lived human
settlement it's 3469 meters above sea
level
it's the highest continuous human
settlement
ever discovered we don't even know how
they lived up there
because if humans spend any time at that
altitude
without you know oxygen and and you know
specialized clothing
they you start to suffer from hypoxia
and extreme weather conditions so we
don't even know how they did it we don't
even know how they survived up there
so the idea then is you know this idea
of a city being founded on the edge of
the world right
that you're sort of like going to the
extreme edge of
being but then you're building a city
there right
um and that's what everything as we
notice like as we look at the tradition
of ethiopia even how even the
the ones that are still alive today in
ethiopia this is what we will see
is that it is a manifestation of the
extremes in almost every case
like everything about this their saints
their stories the things that they
celebrate
it's so it's like this amazing uh this
amazing capacity to kind of
to move into these extremes and and and
and so it's it you'll see we'll see it
as we talk about it people will see how
it manifests it's pretty amazing so if
once you start to understand that
there's this overlap
and this polyvalence between india and
ethiopia you know the extreme east and
the extreme west
uh we can understand the way what you
just said like the way that ethiopia
participates in the symbolism of being
the extreme edge of something right
that it's both the source of great
wealth this is where all the really
great gold comes from right solomon gets
it you know
when the queen of sheba comes uh you
know she brings spices spices that
nobody's ever
you know beaten like these are the best
spices that anyone has ever seen right
so it's a source of great wealth of
great potential
it's also a source of great danger yeah
um
and so this danger is often expressed in
the scriptures as being
um and i'm gonna tease the queen of
sheba but we can't get there yet
but so just just uh but but it's
it's often expressed in the scriptures
as being sort of like the mysterious
feminine or even the idea of what
what you know the book of proverbs would
call the strange woman
and the idea is that a stranger who
comes as a captive
but then who captivates in her turn
so uh there's this reference in ezekiel
when it talks about ethiopia it speaks
of it as being the land of
all of the mingled people um
uh and uh it says ethiopia and libya and
lydia and all the megal people in chubb
and the men of the land that is in
league
shall fall fall by the sword so it's
this is a prophecy
but the reference here to ethiopia is as
ethiopia is a land of mingled people
and um and of course you've talked a lot
about
hybridity being on the edge so when we
come to the edge of something this is
what we would expect to find
yeah and you can see like that's why
uh that's why for example in the greek
culture the sphinx was said to come from
ethiopia
right but the sphinx is uh is this
hybrid it's
dangerous but it also hides a secret
it keeps this secret and if you can
unlock
the secret of the sphinx then you have
access to
this almost like secret knowledge or
this secret all these these these
possibilities that you didn't have
before but it's also dangerous if you
play with it
then it can eat right so
um and on any level you want to look at
this is true like ancient ethiopia
itself was made up of multiple nations
like
it would be way too complicated and
time-consuming to talk about like
all the different dynasties and
migrations and things like this um
and although they're sort of originally
what is considered an afro-asiatic or
uh or afro-asian or an or a kushite
language that's actually kush
like gave his name to that particular
family of languages even today
um they're made up of multiple nations
and so uh they came to speak a semitic
language
um so this this it's this kushite people
who then come to speak a semitic
language through the
through an influx of a group a people
group called the sabians
who are uh descendants of of shem in the
biblical and the biblical narrative so
they represent this
very interesting kind of a hybrid
between the gentile and the jew
yeah between the the descendants of ham
and the sentence of shem
and this is a hybrid that results
let's say in certain elements of the
original becoming more
extroverted and therefore more strongly
preserved
um and by the way this is you you see
the same kind of hybrid
repeated for instance on a smaller scale
in somewhere like samaria
so the samaritans were originally this
this uh you know in the biblical story
they're this hybrid
between you know the nations that the
assyrians brought in who intermarry with
the israelites who are left in the land
right
and so they develop their own particular
culture their own particular
religion um and even though
they're excluded from the jewish people
through you know through whom salvation
comes as christ says
they do preserve certain things that we
you know for instance their version of
the torah
agrees more closely with like the dead
sea scrolls
and the and the the septuagint than
the masoretic text yeah the modern like
the medieval hebrew attacks that
everyone uses for the hebrew bible now
so it's like
it's like they're more they're they're
they're a hybrid but
somehow that hybridity has resulted in
preserving a more extreme or more
extroverted
element of the original yeah and the way
to understand that in terms of pattern
is to understand that the edge of the
world is also a container
and so if you can understand the world
as a as the mountain as the pyramid the
way i show it the bottom of the world's
like a cup
and so things get preserved in the cup
right no that it it the edge of the
world is a place where things get
get preserved in a way that
how can i say that like you said
preserved outside of
almost kind of outside of the narrative
in a way they're just kind of held there
almost like
uh in as a secret that's hidden in the
waters or this
pearl that's hidden in the field and so
you can imagine something like ethiopia
the edge of the world as the field
in which the pearl gets hidden and the
fish in the bottom of you know the fish
shining in the ocean
it's all of that type of imagery that
that the edge also can represent
we were we were talking a little bit
earlier before we hit the record button
about the symbolism of the nest right so
the nest is something that's made up of
remainders it's like little bits of twig
and fur and
lint and whatever else but then the it
forms a protective
you know shelter around around the egg
the seed of life right
at the center right when i i think
there's something something similar
going on here right
yeah and you can understand why then
something like the ark of the covenant
has
cherubs on it yes but it has these
hybrid creatures on it as a kind of seat
you know
talk about the mercy seat or whatever it
might be a bad inter a bad translation
but
there's a reason why we say that that
it's like this container this resting
place
right for the glory uh and it's and and
so
this is all of these things are kind of
coming together as we understand
the role that ethiopia plays in these
stories so before we can get to the
queen of sheba
there's actually an like uh let's say a
prototype
of the queen of sheba in the scriptures
and this is something that maybe a lot
of people don't know about
um but this is the this is moses either
first or second wife
uh there's no there's no clear
chronology for this in the scriptures
um but according to legend according to
legend it's
it's it's moses first wife so i so let
me just ask you a question have you ever
seen
the charlton heston ten commandments
film where charlton heston is moses
right
yeah so remember at the beginning of
that movie when moses is just coming
back from
like his successful war uh in ethiopia
and like they bring he brings in like
the king and the princes of the
ethiopians
and there's this very strong subtext
that at some point that princess and
moses got it on
like it's it's their their you know
everyone's picking up on it nefertieri
is definitely picking up on it
okay if you haven't seen this movie
everyone i mean it's a great movie and
it's very symbolically uh
rich i think it's an interesting film
but anyway
uh it's it's a it's a it's kind of a
classic uh so
it i watched that movie like a million
times as a kid
um so many times um what i didn't
realize until
much later on is that that particular
princess of the ethiopians is an actual
like she's a person she's a historical
you could say like a legendary person
okay so and there's this there's this
very cryptic
mention of this and as far as the only
mention of this in scripture
it's in numbers chapter 12 verse one it
says and miriam and aaron spake against
moses
because of the ethiopian woman whom he
had married for he had married an
ethiopian woman
and it's just mentioned there and it
never comes up again okay but in
ancient legend like ancient jewish
legend uh
uh and this is actually it's referenced
by saint irenaeus right so one of the
apostolic fathers
actually refers to this legend as
something that the jewish community of
his time and he considered to be
credible yeah that moses that moses
reigned in ethiopia was the king of
ethiopia
and so what so the legends like people
are going to freak out and they've been
never heard
of i know saying it i don't know it's
totally normal so the legend here
is that uh is that this princess her
name is starbus
okay um and she was actually moses first
wife
whom he married while he was still a
prince of egypt so the legend concerning
her this is very important
is that he was besieging the city where
she lived
and she saw him from the city walls fell
in love with him from a distance and
then met him secretly and offered to
turn the city over to him
if he would marry her in return so this
is the legend that saint irenaeus refers
to
so in in later medieval legend there's
like an expansion upon this
uh which is that after they get married
moses is like well now that i've
conquered ethiopia uh
it's time for me to head back home to
egypt and tharbis
is refuses to let him do this and so
moses makes uh moses as we're told is is
the most skilled man in astronomy
which means magic uh in the world and so
he makes two magical rings one which
makes the wearer forgetful and the other
one which
makes the the the where remember
everything so it's the right hand left
hand right
so he keeps the s the for the second
ring the one
that makes you remember everything and
then he gives the forgetfulness ring to
tharbus
and once she forgets about him he
escapes away into egypt
this is a very interesting legend i
think um and though
this this doesn't seem totally
compatible with let's say the biblical
chronology
and like you just gotta not worry about
that uh because it is it is a it is a
legend like even in the middle ages they
would have been like you know this is a
fun story
yeah but uh but numbers chapter 12 does
seem to indicate that moses ethiopian
wife is either with him at this time
or that uh you know even though we don't
get a
timeline from when he might have married
her so is this moses first wife is it
his second wife
uh it doesn't it doesn't totally matter
for our purposes
what what does kind of matter is why is
this something that miriam
and aaron are objecting to and of course
i've heard people say well this is like
an
early example of racism or something
like that but you have to understand
we know from linguistic evidence that a
whole lot of the people
uh from the tribe of aaron are black um
and if you if you're curious about this
um father stephen the young talks about
it quite a bit in his uh
in his uh his podcast the whole council
of god which is like a bible study
podcast you can just go listen
to him talk about the evidence for this
yeah um so it's not the fact that she's
black it's the fact that she's an
ethiopian right yeah
but i think i think look i when i read
it i think that
it's not in it's not the same in terms
of racial in terms of racial rights but
there seems to be something about her
being dark in the story
and i'll tell you why because miriam
miriam is basically criticizing moses
because he has a foreign wife it's
mostly
the most foreign wife you could say so
but it there is something about her
being dark
right also being foreign is already
being dark like yeah i'm
i'm yeah i'm not trying to say and of
course miriam her
her punishment is leprosy right but it
all but in this it's not just leprosy
like the way it's described is that
her her her punishment is that her her
skin becomes white
yeah and so right it's like she she
criticizes
she's acting like what i call an excess
of purity she's criticizing
moses for not being pure enough and then
as her punishment is to become
so pure that she can't function in
society anymore
yes and she has to be excluded because
she's too pure in a bad in a bad sense
like she doesn't
she doesn't have access to to others
anymore yeah and i'm i'm not
yeah let me clarify and say i'm not
trying to separate
the darkness of her skin from her being
an ethiopian i'm trying to separate like
our
our current moment yeah and are some of
our current hang-ups
uh around race uh from what's going on
here
right because because they're not i mean
they're they're close and they seem
close enough that we could just like
read in
what we're dealing with as a culture
right now and that would actually cause
us to miss something really important in
the story
uh which is that which is that you know
this manifestation
like the the manifestation of the
extreme version of the strange woman
yeah right uh this is the this is the
one who
is captured and in her turn conquers
her conqueror and by the way there's
another african queen she's not
ethiopian but there's another african
queen
lady named cleopatra who
manifests this unlike not it's not even
a legendary level like
it's it's it's totally it's completely
historical right that's the trope
the trope of caesar is exactly that
trope yeah
of being captured by this stranger that
this like strange woman
who fascinates right and so remember
that one of the possible etymologies
of ethiopia of ethiopian is the steeler
of the heart
yeah right one who you know that can
play out on kind of multiple levels
we talked about the arc in a minute i
think that's really it's
a nice it's really on the nose i don't
know happens moment but but but you can
see this happening with
with tharbus right that that she uh
she's conquered by moses but then she
steals moses heart
um and so and it's again i i think that
there's probably like a lot more to that
story into that legend
uh than just what i'm bringing out here
maybe this will just like introduce
people
to something they probably didn't know
about moses
yeah um um uh yeah so
so this brings us then to the queen of
sheba right
so the the the details that were given
in about the queen of sheba these come
primarily in first kings chapter 10 our
first
uh or which is also like if you've got
an orthodox study bible third kingdoms
chapter 10 it's the same book
so uh and we're basically told that when
she
hears the fame of solomon concerning the
name of yahweh
she came to him to prove him with hard
questions
so she comes posing a riddle and you
mentioned the sphinx earlier
right yeah um so she comes to him and
she brings
tremendous wealth with her uh we're told
that she comes to jerusalem with a very
great train
camels that bear spices much gold
precious stones
right so basically the whole figurative
wealth of the east
right she brings with her and
she comes and she comes to him and it
first says that she tried him with hard
questions
and then it says that she communed with
him
of all that was in her heart
so yes that solomon told her all of the
questions there was nothing hid from the
king which he told her not
and when she saw his wisdom uh then she
speaks of speaks of his fame she blesses
his god
etc and she gives him a bunch of gold
spice is a very
very great store precious stones um
and you have to understand this there's
so much going on in this story like
there's so many layers
because it also has to do with the
feminine itself right
but the feminine which which is a
question which which
which asks to be answered just like the
mother of god asking christ
posing a problem like saying they have
here's a problem solve it you know and
everybody
under anybody who's married who has
relationship with women understands this
relationship like the woman frames the
the situation
ask the question the neck right that
tells you where to look and then and
then the masculine kind of answers or
attempts to answer let's say and so it's
like this idea of like the
the woman as bringing a question a
mystery that needs to be solved
a puzzle that needs to be answered and
then that is how
the seduction happens right right it's
like
in answering her question in resolving
her puzzle
then that is how they commune that's how
they commune into her heart like let's
say
it becomes a very sexual imagery so to
sort of speak
to of things too high for me for a
moment okay
this is the relationship that the church
has with christ
you know that that and and and that's uh
that's a really that's a really strange
thing to me
you know you don't think of yourself as
like posing a question to christ
right but but and and this is where
this is where attempts to like define
the church
that are you know let's say
i i don't want to just like pick on on
like western christianity but this is
where
where attempts to define the church that
are aren't able to see it as the bride
right they're not able to see as the
feminine
right and so and so they you you attempt
to nail down what the churches and let's
say just a really masculine way
and hopefully people will know what i
mean by that yeah uh they
they they it's not just that they're
wrong it's more like they're
unconvincing like they're they're
there's nothing beautiful about them
like it might be the sort of thing that
offers a like a high degree of certainty
okay i know who is in
and i know who's out right and that's
really attractive
for a little while but but it's got no
power to seduce
it's got no power to really like charm
you and draw you in and
and i mean similarly um you can take
different approaches to talking about
the mother of god but ultimately the
best
the best approach is really not to talk
about her um you know it's
you know it's the case an icon and and
it just sort of sort of i don't know
it's
it's uh it's a really mysterious thing
and what's here so here's what's
interesting
is that in medieval iconography the
queen of sheba is used
to represent both the church and
in particular the gentile church the
gentile nations coming to christ
but also the image of the queen of sheba
enthroned
was seen as a prototype in medieval arts
especially medieval western art
of the coronation of the virgin yeah so
this is interesting because you have
this
this figure who she's a gentile she
either is either seduced by or seduces
solomon
you know and a lot of a lot of medieval
commentators saw her
as being being the the historical
context for the song of songs
yeah that she's the schulemai yeah yeah
that solomon talks and she says i am
i am i am dark but fair right
you know so but you can understand then
why this would come into the church as
being an
image right and and why for example like
you would have a tradition of black
madonna's that would appear
in western christianity which happened
almost accidentally like the black
madonna's in terms of
material causes it's just because the
wood gets darker with time and the smoke
and everything
but that people would celebrate this
image of the dark madonna
as the idea of pure possibility or this
pure potential which is offered up and
which is
kind of asking for enlightenment which
is which is becoming pure in in this
is becoming dark right and becoming just
pure space
and so that's our role as the church
right that's what we do
we we try to eliminate our own thoughts
and eliminate our own passions
to then be open up to the illumination
that christ offers us and so it
does end up being this masculine
feminine relationship so
and you'll also enjoy this because we've
talked a lot about the sibling oracles
most medieval authors who were reading
the sibling oracles believed that one of
the sybils identified in there was the
queen of sheba
so she's she's also she's also connected
to this
late antiquity early medieval oracular
tradition
um so the reveal it's like the revealing
of of the mystery
you know but even then the mystery is
like veiled in a mystery you know it's
like
it's like revealing but also you know
concealing yeah
uh one might say so this story
here uh the story of solomon it's the
beginning of a long history of
interaction between let's say ethiopian
culture and judaism
now to speak from a modern historical
perspective for just a quick
just a quick second just a quick second
uh
historians don't agree on exactly when
the current consensus seems to be that
sometime around the eighth century
uh which is about three centuries after
probably when solomon lived
um but there was we know that from the
historical record
sometime at or before the eighth century
there was a huge influx of jewish
settlers who came to live in ethiopia
uh they brought with them not just
jewish customs but also jewish religious
practices
there are actual jewish temples that
were built in ethiopia for
this one at yaha in the in the tigre
province yeah uh which
which is very old um and it's believed
to basically be an architectural copy of
the jerusalem temple yeah um and uh
there are other examples for instance on
some of the monastery islands of lake
tana
which you were just talking about um
there's there are some ancient
stone altars dating back to 800 years
before
christ wow um which
seemed to have been built in the manner
of jewish sacrificial altars
they've and they've been profound found
not only preserved in good condition but
still containing blood residue
in the way that the altar is purified
with the sprinkling of blood in the
jewish ritual
you know of you know of atonement so
uh all of this seems to have indicated
that 800 years before christ
there is a culture in ethiopia
that is already strongly adhering to
some
version of mosaic law and it's not
exactly because
obviously they're not going to the
jerusalem temple to worship so this
i mean we could say from a perspective
of you know old testament
you know religion this is problematic um
but the point here um is that but it is
also it was problematic when the
the temple was destroyed and it was
problematic when when the jews right
scattered in different
so it was like it wasn't like the ideal
situation right imagine these well but
but even
even in the even in the old testament
you know one of the things you're not
supposed to do is like build a high
place you know you're supposed to go
worship at the tabernacle this isn't
like
the era of the judges and the early
kings before the
the temple is built you're not supposed
to build a high place you're supposed to
go worship at the temple or the
tabernacle
but then we find people like the prophet
samuel going and offering sacrifices at
the high places all the time so it's
like well
i don't know it's complicated i don't
know what's going on here
uh god apparently knows but uh and
what's fascinating about the ethiopians
in terms of this these proofs that
people find is that
the ethiopians have no desire to like
prove to the modern world that they are
what they say they
are right this altar that they found and
that they have
they have proof that they were able to
get blood samples or whatever there's
other stuff there that they don't oh
yeah i show you oh yeah i care to show
you they don't
want they don't need to prove to all you
scholars that they are what they say
they are they know what they are
so so i think that uh the stories of
this connection we have and there are
legends about this that get written down
in the middle ages but i think they
really
represent some much older oral history
um and i'm not the sort of person who by
the way when i say oral history
thinks that's unreliable right remember
that socrates
basically said well oral history is
reliable it's when people start writing
things down that we're going to be in
trouble you know
so it's so i'm i'm definitely not of the
opinion that oral history is in any way
like less reliable than what's written
but uh
uh so so the
the story about solomon and sheba and
i'll just go off of the uh off of the
ethiopian version of it here since you
know
there's actually there's actually so
much material written in jewish
christian and islamic sources in the
middle ages about the queen of sheba
that you could fill an entire library
with it like there's just so much
written
there's all kinds of stuff but to just
go off of the
to go off of the the the
ethiopian version of the story um
we're told that the queen of sheba whose
name in the ethiopian is
uh makita or makata um again
if i'm sure there are people out there
uh like my buddy john wayne coatney who
actually knows how to say all these
ethiopian words and i'm just super sorry
for getting it all wrong i'm just a dumb
anglo uh
but but uh uh queen queen makita
uh makes it a pilgrimage to jerusalem
and by the way some scholars think that
makita is
is the like that candace is like a is
like a
uh the candace the ethiopian in
queen in in the book of acts that that
that's actually some rendering of makita
in greek
okay and that that's actually a title as
like like caesar would be and
yeah yeah yeah in in roman culture so
she makes this pilgrimage to jerusalem
she wants to hear solomon she test him
during her stay so going back to this
idea of the strange woman the one who
was captured
but then also captures uh she she
becomes so enraptured solomon becomes so
enraptured with her beauty
that he just decides he's gotta have her
of course this is a thing that solomon
you know is it was a thing um and so
so that the story and i'm going to just
tell you this story and then
i want you to just like help me
understand it symbolically because it's
very strange
um so no pressure you're on the air uh
so
so one evening he orders his royal cooks
to uh increase the amount of pepper
in the meal that they're being served
for dinner but he also orders
the water bearers not to bring water to
anyone unless they're
specifically authorized to do it and
then to place a really big jug of water
in his bed chamber
and so queen makita she realizes his
trickery she plays along thinking that
she can just go without water for the
evening
but eventually she becomes dehydrated
the pepper is too much
and so she finally gives up and goes to
his bed chamber and ends up
sleeping with him right and this affair
leads to the birth of their son
uh menelik the first who is like the
first solomonic what's called the
solomonic
dynasty the first solomonic king of
ethiopia
now what the heck is going on with the
water in the pepper jonathan pageot
okay well i mean for sure it has to do
with trickery that is the first thing
and i think
the all the different versions of how
they end up together
uh is always has to do with some kind of
trickery
right uh but it's like a trickery that
she is also conceding to it's not
it's not obviously it wouldn't it's
problematic for our
like standard sure sure and today
whatever but like in terms of of the
story it's the idea that
that he's trying to trick her into
giving in to him
and so that's the first thing um and so
then the second thing has to do with the
difference between water and spice
uh and so spice is the extreme
right it's it's the extreme in the sense
of
it's like it's the flavor without the
the the
meal it's the flavor without the the
it doesn't sustain you right it's flavor
without sustainment
and so that's what spices and so you it
has to do with the foreigner
themselves right foreigners are like
spice
in in in a in a system strangeness is
like spice
so you want a little bit in order to
kind of saying that saying variety is
the spice of life
right it's it's exactly variety is the
spice of life that's good that you went
there yeah
um and so so that so there's a
relationship between spice and
strangeness because
it's like these things like you're
eating what you're eating potatoes and
so
it's like you don't want to you add
something to it to make it
different from potatoes it's still
basically potato but it has a
it has an extra an extra kind of
a next extra aspect to it to to
titillate you let's say
and so that's what so that's what's
going on and so he's he's trading
he's giving water for spice so he's he's
giving he's spicing her
up like making her what she is nice and
then he's offering
water and so it's there's a relationship
between it's not the same people are
going to get
right but how christ offers
the source to the samaritan woman right
it's like source of life
so this is what's this is what's going
on now the water becomes
like active water you could say not
passive water like the ocean
but like fresh water is a way to
understand it so he's offering her
fresh water which comes down and then
she's full of spice and she's full of
this strangeness
so it's it makes sense in terms of the
basic symbolic
pattern i think i think that it's uh
there's two biblical associations that
come
readily to minor one that and of course
this is part of what's going on in the
story of the samaritan woman
is that the patriarchs always meet their
wife by a well
right it's always it's they always meet
their wife by the well
uh but then but then also even even in
proverbs when solomon
right is talking about the strange woman
that's how he presents it
he and what he'll say is drink waters
from your own well drink waters from
your own cistern he says don't let your
fountain run into the streets
right so but solomon does that like
solomon does exactly that and christ
does that too it's just that christ
succeeds
like christ his water flowing into the
streets doesn't disperse him
whereas uh like in in the sense of the
way solomon talks about the strange
woman it's like it leads to death
right so but there's a mystery there's
this mystery there because death
or the edge or the limit is also
potential
and so that's why the queen of sheba
brings riches
because she's offering more body you
could say she's she has more body she's
further out she has
she's out on the limit and shows the
offering more potential
for solomon to to let's say to
just to pour his water over let's say
and like kind of fill
but but it's a dangerous game like it's
a dangerous game
and that's what happens in the legend of
solomon right at least in the camera and
the gas
right it's a dangerous game because it
leads to the ark being stolen
right so so the the the
the so that's that's where this legend
goes right and and that's that
metallic is raised by his mother as a
jew in ethiopia
until he's in his 20s and he goes to
jerusalem to meet his father for the
first time
right and there are different varieties
of the story but in the one that you
just referenced which is kind of the
most common version
uh he is he either either refuses or is
refused the throne
after solomon's death like solomon wants
him to become king but he's either not
will
uh willing to succeed him because he
wants to live in ethiopia or
the elders of israel are not having it
you know like one of
those are two different versions of the
same thing but essentially he can't
become king or he's refused the throne
after solomon's death and so he sends
his servants to break into the temple
and to steal the ark of the covenant and
take it back with them to ethiopia
and when solomon discovers what they've
done
he allows it and he the reason that he
allows it is that he believes that god
has allowed the theft
he believes that you know if god had i
mean this is the ark we all know what
happens when you touch the ark without
permission
right and so the fact that that nobody
has died
solomon takes as being a sign that that
this is something that god has allowed
yeah and this is the legend of how the
ark gets to ethiopia
and then there's so much like i wish i
could unpack
i could unpack this for hours because
there's so much mystery
in this event and there's so much going
on
and it helps you understand how
symbolism is neither
just positive or just negative right
because the imagery that is used to tell
that story is the very imagery in
proverbs when
when king solomon says like don't go to
the
to the strange woman because you'll lose
the strength of your work
right like you'll actually this your
strengths will be dispersed into the
edge and you'll
you'll lose the the fruits of your labor
and it's like that's exactly what
happens to him
right but then it ends up in the end
working towards this kind of universal
salvation
which is the surprise like this kind of
weird surprise at how things flip
you know god uses things and turns them
on their head and bring them back to
to participate in salvation let's say so
you have
so you remember then that the again
one of the possible meanings of
ethiopian is the steeler of the heart
yeah right that the the queen of sheba
comes and
we could say in like you know in our
modern romantic
parlance you know we say oh she's she
stole solomon's heart
but then like she literally stole the
heart
comes and steals the heart of israel
star steals the heart of you know
the the the visible presence of yahweh
among his people
and i understand that this is a story
that the ethiopians tell like this is
right
yeah like their sacred history yes so
they understand their origin
as a theft a relationship so
i've talked about this before where the
relationship with the stranger is often
a relationship
of trickery because we're not in the
same identity and so
what happens in the end are these
ironies and flips and and switches
that are what trickery is about like how
jacob acts in the in
in in the lab in laban's uh laban's
court and how laban acts with him
are these relationships of trickery like
of trying to to trick the other and so
you see this as
the very origin the way that the
ethiopians understand themselves
as their origin um and
anyways but it plays out it plays out in
the whole story as
as as something amazing but it's it's
just important to understand that that
even in the story of king solomon
how he tricks uh the queen of sheba to
sleep with them and then he ends up
being tricked
where as the ark is stolen out and so
see the story of of jacob
how he tricks he tricks uh uh layman
tricks jacob
and jacob tricks laban and then he
steals the idols from
right house and brings them out it's
like this is the same story that's going
on
and even the the uh
even the the two the two uh
the the jacob's two wives right you know
which
which have all this varied symbolic
resonance you know the
the act of life and contemplative life
and things like this but they're also
the
the wife of your youth and the strange
woman right because one of the things
one of the paradoxes about the strange
woman is this strange woman is like uh
um she's usually not fertile right
you know she because she can't give you
she can't give you a legitimate heir
yeah right and so so then like jacob has
these two wives and like
his heart is drawn after one of them but
it's the other one that keeps giving him
heirs
you know and uh but the same thing with
moses right moses has two wives
right he's got zipporah who's not an
ethiopian she's a you know she's a
ishmaelite midianite right um and then
you and then you have
uh so she's she's semitic she's oh she's
she's of an abrahamic people you could
say
um and she gives him his legitimate son
but even there there's something about
moses where he's like unable to
i mean talk about circumcision right
he's unable to cut off the remainder
right and so he still has this ethiopian
wife he doesn't circumcise his son
you know there's something about that
that i think is is really interesting
and i think part of
part of what's really interesting here
is that the legend is
that solomon had many many wives
obviously
but the only ones who ever produced him
a son
were the queen of sheba and then the
mother of rehoboam whose name i can't
remember right now
um so rehoboam is the king whose
arrogance and foolishness
is eventually results in the splitting
of the kingdoms yeah
and so the idea seems to be here in the
legend that if solomon's son menelik
could have been
the good son who kept the king like he
could have been the good son the good
heir
who actually kept the kingdom from
falling apart if he could have stayed
but of course he can't stay for various
reasons ultimately
because it's not part of his the pattern
that he's in yeah and it's convenient in
the legend because metallic steals the
ark and then israel gets set then israel
falls apart
it's like that's the actual hidden cause
of the separate
the breakdown of yeah yeah and so
so you know he returns to his native
land he takes the heart with him
right um and what this
ironically does then if you follow the
legend is that it allows the ark to be
preserved
after the babylonian conquest yeah right
that's the mystery of the edge like this
it's like a scandal right then then it
turns into a mysterious
keeping so the symbol of the symbolism
of ethiopia seems to be on an intuitive
level
is really again talking about the nest
right the idea that's
it's it's this collection of the
remainder but the remainder becomes a
safe space in which the egg
the seed of new life the heart of
something can be hidden
and protected and of course there's a
historical site the the rulers of
ethiopia
and we probably shouldn't talk too much
about this in this video but the rulers
of ethiopia
still take the title the line of judah
you know
um you know uh quite recently because
they
they contin they they trace their
lineage all the way back to
solomon yeah um so amazing i don't know
how we're doing on time i don't know i
think we could
if you're okay i think we should keep
going okay yeah we've got good stuff and
we just let's keep going because
i want to get into i want to get into uh
ethiopia
at least start teasing the role of
ethiopia in the christian story yeah
that we've kind of laid this
this we've laid this groundwork and
we've established the basic pattern
right so that's the symbolic identity of
ethiopia as the extreme edge the
outsider the hybrid the strange woman
right but then this idea you know if you
think all of the stuff is totally
negative
that's going to be really complicated by
the old testament by by the prophecies
of the old testament itself
yeah and some stories in the old
testament yeah yeah
so there's there's an idea that the that
this is also part of resurrection
right there's an aspect of resurrection
which is related to this change this
weird flip that happens
in death and the best image of it is
jeremiah
who is in the cistern and it's a really
fascinating
image because jeremiah is in the cistern
and he's kind of stuck there
and he's in he's in this like mire you
know how the psalmist talks about
sinking into the mire and all that stuff
right so there he is in the mire
and the person who pulls jeremiah out is
an ethiopian
he pulls him out with rotten rags and so
he
he he put these rotten rags around him
and he pulled him out of the system
it's like if you want to understand the
mystery of resurrection there's
something about
about that about about the relationship
with
uh the relationship you have to you have
to
for resurrection to happen there has to
be reconciliation with the stranger
because it's a you the universal story
has to not
you have to find a way to bring this all
together like all of it has to fit
and so the idea that in the end so it i
mean and you have it
there's a like the scandal of of of
resurrection has to do with that and and
it
you see that in christianity one of the
reasons why romans become christians
has to do with this scandal of the the
stranger becoming the stranger
participating in the the return of the
seed
right uh so there are these
there these prophecies let's for
instance in the psalms psalm 68
in the like the numbering most people
use uh
talks about princes coming out of egypt
and ethiopia shall soon stretch out her
hands unto god
and now this particular line that
ethiopia will stretch out her hands of
the god this becomes
really important in the way that
ethiopia is viewed in the byzantine and
byzantine apocalyptic tradition so maybe
just bracket that
because that's that's gonna have to be
another video um
it's like the ultimate tease i know i
know like how the
relationship between ethiopia and like
the end of the end of everything and the
right
the final resolution yes yes literally
the end of everything right ethiopia
shall soon stretch out her hands under
god
psalm 87 speaks this is one of my
favorite psalms i think that we read it
uh every every monday or not every
monday every wednesday night
uh in the orthodox church at wednesday
vespers so so we hear i always hear this
i hear the psalm read every week
and uh it goes a little bit differently
in the septuagint translation we use in
my parish but
in the king james it says i will make
mention of rahab and babylon to them
that know me behold philistia entire
with ethiopia this man was born there
the idea is that people from the edges
of the world right from all of these
these places and and these these places
function differently
babylon is not the same as ethiopia
symbolically it's a totally different
you know kind of a thing philistia is
more closely related to ethiopia
um tyre you know so but the idea is that
all these different gentile nations with
all of their symbolic resonance that the
people from these nations are going to
say of jerusalem
that's my city i was born in her and of
course the
of course the uh the the most important
ethiopian church
uh which is in the in the town of oxum
today
uh which is sort of the spiritual heart
of of ethiopia is
saint mary of zion um that's the church
yeah
and um and of course the the church
fathers read this particular psalm as
resonant speaking both of the church and
the mother of god right as
as mary mary is sort of the the new
jerusalem somehow
and that's why he man if you go to
ethiopia it it just becomes so
intense in terms of seeing that because
ethiopians
seem to identify themselves as mary
like in a very mysterious analogical way
there's an image
in uh in one of the churches i forget
the name of the
the place where all the little angels
are at on the on the ceiling
um where they they they where they have
the the great theophany uh festival i
forget the name of the church i'm sorry
um but in that church there's an image
of mary
who's who's in the shape of ethiopia
like oh man so i got a little like ever
ahead and she's holding and then the the
her veil like ah her veil kind of falls
at the bottom of how she's presented
she's actually taking up the shape of
ethiopia oh my goodness it's pretty
amazing
yeah i'm gonna have to look for that um
oh maybe i can add it and when we edit
this
yeah that would be good that would be
good and then i'll watch the video so i
can see you can see it so i can see it
um yeah so so there's this so the idea
is that
that this the ultimate stranger right
would then
identify with the ultimate center of
things and and i personally have to say
that i love this verse
i love the song because for me as a
as a you know i'm a gentile i'm a
you know a wasp i'm a like
i live in north texas of all places
right
for me to be able to say zion is my city
and i was born in her
right uh that's you know with with all
of the sort of the mystical layers
that that entails to me that's a deeply
there's actually a deeply comforting
thing
comforting thing and it's deeply
reaffirming of
of my identity in christ you know as as
part of as part of the church
so uh so there's there's this idea
that that the ethiopians are going to be
drawn to jerusalem they'll identify it
they'll claim their lineage from it
and they'll worship the god of israel
and
because of the symbolism the queen of
sheba is often
as i mentioned earlier she's used the
medieval iconography as a type
of sort of a shorthand of the entire
gentile church
yeah that the hybrid the multiplicity of
all the nations of the gentiles
is united in the with the center in such
a way
that it actually preserves the unity and
the unique identity of the people of god
yeah that's the image like just the
image of pentecost the ancient image of
pentecost is having all the nations
gathered into the
door to receive the spirit of god like
that is this
the queen of sheba is a condensation of
that type of imagery
and this is also what i mean would say
paul talks about the gentiles becoming
sort of the ultimate means of salvation
for the jews
you can even see that playing out in a
symbolic level in that
only in ethiopia is a certain form of
judaism preserved
that was actually kind of like the
dominance one of the dominant strains of
judaism at the time of christ
you know but but it hasn't it hasn't
been preserved anywhere else
and even even things like uh even things
like
some of the some of the let's see the
crazier you know scriptural books things
like enoch and jubilees which which
aren't in our canon
you know and they're not in any
certainly they're way outside any
western canon
you know but in ethiopia they were
preserved and the reason that they're
preserved in ethiopia
is because they'd already been preserved
by the jewish community of ethiopia
so these are like these are really
important texts to what
a lot of people call second temple
judaism or second temple judaisms
these are really important texts but
it's only in ethiopia that they really
survive and so but it's so fascinating
to see how the layers
come together which is the idea that
ethiopia
has the arc the idea that ethiopia has
all these texts
it's like ethiopia is the ark it has it
is the place where things end up kind of
being preserved this
this box this home this this this hidden
place where
where you know where you put you know
it's like the in the ark what did they
put they put
they put the the the ten commandments
they put the staff
they had these they had the mana they
had these these
uh tokens of the tradition which were
held in the box
so you can understand that that's what
ethiopia the role that ethiopia kind of
played even in terms of
modern bible scholarship like without
ethiopia
the narrative of the book of enoch would
not be full we wouldn't have this full
and it's playing a role like just like
the lord of spirits it's playing a role
in
in what's going on like this restoration
of christianity it's going to vote
through that type of story that's the
thing like i don't know if this is too
crazy to say
you know on a recording or not i guess
you can edit it out if it is but like
you wouldn't be doing the thing you're
doing right now without ethiopia exactly
you're like lord of spirits wouldn't be
a podcast right now without ethiopia
no you're totally right there is there
is something happening like in terms of
the
the the capacity to recapture the
ancient story
to recapture let's say that more
mythical aspects of christianity
are coming through what the ethiopians
have have
preserved and have kept uh but but it's
it's more than that like
it's hard to explain to people it's more
than that because the magical
world is still alive in ethiopia like
th this kind of enchanted reality is
still there
if you go there you'll you'll you can't
get around it
like this i was in i was in on a
mountaintop and this
this insane mountain top is super high
up it took us like
half a day to go up there and then you
wake up on a sunday morning
and you look out in the valley and you
see all these little white dots
that are that are climbing up the
mountain just to go to church
and they're going into this cave where
this church is and you know that there's
they're like walking for two hours just
to two three hours just to
come to church on a sunday and to ascend
this mountain to be in this cave
and you're thinking like where else like
where else
is this even possible it's just
astounding
man i don't man like i don't know what
to say because
i complain because i've got to drive and
drive i was just thinking in five
minutes
yeah i was just thinking about my
30-minute drive to my parish and like
lord of mercy yeah let's all be shamed
but we yeah getting said to be shamed
okay so
so so uh so
the so the the queen of shiva
right like she represents both the
church right the gentile church but also
we see this this movement from the
strange woman to the to
the new jerusalem of course we have this
wonderful hymn that we sing instead of
it is truly meet during the
possible season which is now past you
know uh sp
singing seeing you know the angel cry to
the lady full of grace it's this
announcement of the
enunciation if you will of the
resurrection to the virgin but then
she's
but then we sing shine shine oh new
jerusalem so that hinography
closely identifies it's not the only
place obviously it's very frequently
found in our tradition but
the hymnography closely identifies the
virgin with the new jerusalem
and so we see uh the enthroned queen of
sheba
being used in medieval art to represent
the coronation
of the virgin mary um and so
uh so there's there's uh uh
all of this kind of culminates in the
ethiopian eunuch
which is maybe i think we'll get to the
ethiopian eunuch and then maybe we could
just tease
the business the next stuff for the next
time yeah yeah all right yeah
um and i've got a great teaser for that
so okay so
so with the ethiopian eunuch you have to
remember what's the ethiopian eunuch
reading
when philip meets him on the road he's
reading
the scroll of the book of isaiah and of
course
he's very famously reading that you know
chapter 53
which is about the suffering servant
right
but if you go to the book of isaiah and
you look at the stuff that comes before
that and after that of course he's
reading on a scroll
so you don't flip around on a scroll you
sort of start at one end
and you kind of work your way across a
few chapters
before um talking uh this is in chapter
43 and chapter 45
we say we see yahweh the god of israel
saying i am the lord thy god the holy
one of israel thy savior i give egypt
for thy ransom
and ethiopia and sheba for thee
and then he says uh then he says you
know talks about thus says the lord the
labor of egypt and merchandise of
ethiopia and of the sabians
right the sabians or this group that
came into ethiopia
men of stature they shall come over unto
thee and they shall be thine
they shall come after thee they shall
fall down unto thee they shall make
supplication
unto thee saying surely god is in me and
there is none
else there is no god so here's the
here's the ethiopian eunuch and he's on
the road between ethiopia
and jerusalem and he reads in the scroll
and it says
ethiopians are going to come to
jerusalem and say god is in you
and there is no other god than you you
know
like than your god so then he reads
isaiah chapter 53 and that's when philip
shows up and that's when he gets
baptized
yeah okay but then you go three more
chapters
down and we get this crazy verse in
chapter 56
it says neither let the son of the
stranger
that hath joined himself to the lord
speak saying the lord hath
utterly separated me from his people
neither let the eunuch
say behold i am a dry tree
thus says the lord unto the eunuchs who
keep my sabbaths
and choose the things that please me
take hold of my covenant even unto them
i will give my house and my walls and a
place
and a name better than that of sons and
daughters i will give them an
everlasting name
that will not be cut off that's amazing
i never knew that that was
there like i never knew that that was in
the in isaiah this is like
i mean this is incredible yeah it's
incredible because it's also
there's something about the the the
eunuch it's
it's it's everything about christianity
is in that story in terms of the right
the ethiopian because he is from the
edge of the world he's the
he's the ultimate stranger but he's also
in terms of jewish law he would not have
been allowed to go into the temple
because he was castrated
and so he is he is the reject like he is
really is
he represents the edge in every way you
couldn't be you couldn't be
more on the edge of the ancient jewish
world
than him like because he's both a
gentile he's an ethiopian and he's a
eunuch like it's
he's the mystery that's being shown and
it's being shown in the story is that
the eunuch is like is the garment of
skin
in this story it's because the in the
story it's trying to show you that
there's a relationship between elijah
and the story of the ethiopian eunuch
because when
philip baptizes the eunuch it says that
philip
ascended into heaven and there was no
more and the the text
the the phrase it's used in greek is the
exact same phrase in the septuagint
which it says that elijah went up when
he tried to cross the river
and so this is like the story of
christianity like condensed
into an amazing moment because he
crosses
over the river he goes into death with
the garments of skin
philip goes up like elijah and then the
blessing falls down
on the ethiopian and so now the stranger
becomes the body
of christ basically it's like a little
repetition
of you know of even the ascension of
christ in a way like christ goes up and
then
down below from the body and so this is
what is happening in the story where
this garment of skin is transformed into
a garment of glory before your very
eyes in in in this story the edge
becomes the body of christ and that's
that's and that's exactly what isaiah
says he says
the eunuch will be the house of god yeah
and the eunuch will be the place
where god puts his name right and that
he is going to bring the eunuch to his
holy mountain
in verse 7 of chapter um
and what's really interesting to me is
that this is the context when christ
is in the temple he's purging the temple
and he says it has written my house
shall be a house of prayer
he's quoting this passage that this
passage of
and like this is some symbolism that i'm
still trying to wrap my head around
because
because what christ is doing is an act
of purity
right it's an act of purgation he's pure
he's
purifying the temple because the temple
has been defiled
with commerce but commerce is related to
ethiopia
you know and he's he's he's he's you
know it's the it's the influx of you
know
from the stranger coming in and so he's
he's pure that's what money changing is
too it's about it's about
strange currencies but but and this is
my obligatory ethics of beauty reference
for this video um because i just have to
talk about this book all the time
one of the beautiful things and i think
this is what dr petitta actually did his
whole
dissertation about for his phd but um
is the idea of the liturgy of holy week
as a city founding ritual
and so in the ancient world all these
cities have the
various cities had these city founding
rituals that they would enact every year
and what's what's uh
i mean they're different a little bit
different from city to city but
basically
the pattern would be that the king comes
into the city
and he ascends to the the center of the
city where the holy place is
and he enters into the holy place and he
spends a ritual night with the city
you know of course in a pagan context
this is with like a temple prostitute
but in uh in but what what
dr patiza argues is that is that you can
read especially in the gospel of john
uh and you know that you can actually
read christ's
movement into uh one of the interesting
things that we're we are never told in
the gospels that christ spends the night
in jerusalem
never happens he always goes out of town
to bethany which is like the the
the ghetto right the that's where the
poor are so he always goes outside of
jerusalem to bethany to spend the night
we're never told that he spends the
night in jerusalem so
this is what's really interesting is
that in the the holy week narrative you
have christ ascending
and he gets to the high place he gets
the holy place of the city
but then when he finds this it's totally
defiled yeah so he purges it he cast out
the money changers
and then he leaves the city and goes
outside and the bridal night
for the story of holy week becomes the
bridal chamber of the tomb
yeah and so we see christ sort of like
consummating his relationship with the
new jerusalem
right and constituting a new people so
that's dr uh
petita's argument in his book and in his
phd thesis and i think it's brilliant
but here's the thing christ is saying is
quoting this passage
what is this passage about this passage
is about god
constituting bringing in the stranger
bringing in the eunuch
and constituting a new people of yahweh
the god of israel bringing in the
ethiopian and the eunuch and
saying these this is my people uh and
and what
what constitutes it he refers to it over
and over again as these are the ones who
keep my sabbath
in other words they're the one who
preserved the remainder
right and that this is where he's gonna
put his this is where he's gonna make
his new people so
and and he's referring to that as he's
purging the temple which is somehow
participating in this idea of a
city-founding liturgy and this idea of
so this is a this is an idea that's not
like fully formed in my mind yet but
i've been
i've just been noodling on this a lot
the last few weeks
yeah there's something really mysterious
happening here and always you know
uh father stephen deyoung talked about
this whenever the new old testament is
quoted in the new testament you have to
go back and look at the rest of the
passage
because it's like a hyperlink yeah so
you got to click that
and go to the rest of the passage to see
what is christ talking about
so he's not just saying oh you're
supposed to pray in church
and instead you're selling stuff in
church that's not what he's really
saying at all i mean he is saying that
but what he's really saying is
is i'm going to make a new people for
myself
right he's saying he's saying i'm going
to make a new people for myself i'm
going to make a new temple
right that the temple of my body is
going to be destroyed and it's going to
i'm going to
rebuild it and it's going to be the
church and it's going to bring in these
people
from the edge of things yeah and that's
going to be where i put my name
so you can understand it like you can
maybe understand if you can compare
the money changes to pentecost when
maybe an interesting way to understand
where money changing is like it's like
this equivalency of identities that just
gets kind of traded back and forth and
and there's like you know it's almost
like it really is like this kind of
weird mixture
and and mitigation you could say whereas
pentecost there's a sense in which
the one truth gets embodied in all these
particulars
so the particulars commune together by
by by preserving their particularity but
are able to see each other as
brothers you're not and they're able to
see each other as in a way to transcend
that right it's like
it's a way to transcend their particular
but it doesn't mean it doesn't
it also affirms the reality because
people were hearing their
the they were hearing the the
speech of the apostles in their own
language and so it's like this filling
up
of multiplicity but you're right it's
difficult because
there's like a there's a thing happening
here like in terms of
the place of multiplicity and unity
together how it kind of
how it plays together in christ when it
comes together and it's sometimes not
easy to see through it because it
seems to be so found such foundation
that sometimes it's hard to see the
foundation of something
yeah so maybe at this point i'll just
tease
all right let's go okay so here's the
thing we all know
and i'm sure somebody out there some
some very zealous person out there is
like well
why are richard and jonathan talking so
much about ethiopia ethiopia don't you
know we're in chisholm with them
you know so i'm just going to say this
in the byzantine apocalyptic tradition
there's this idea that the seed of rome
and i really literally mean the seed of
rome because it's the son of romulus
that the seed of rome is preserved in
ethiopia kind of like the
the you know the seed of solomon being
preserved in ethiopia it's the same
pattern
the seed of rome being preserved in
ethiopia but the place where that
happens
in the byzantine apocalypse tradition is
at calcidon
which is where the fourth ecumenical
council right where
where where you know the calcidonian
churches you know and that and the
non-calcedonian churches wanted decision
was at that council so and the thing is
like when that when this is being
written when this prophecy is being
written
this was a few hundred years after that
had happened it's totally deliberate
wow so there's a sense in which there's
a mystery in the separation
right there's the mystery and the
fragmentation of the church
which is going to play out in in in the
apocalypse
yeah that's amazing so it's amazing it's
a little teaser
people need to need to tune in for that
next one we'll talk about ethiopia and
the byzantine apocalyptic tradition
and maybe we can talk and you know more
about this than i do so maybe
maybe we can talk and you can kind of
talk and i'll listen and ask questions
about
about uh ethiopia today and about you
know
recent history you know there's there's
this recent emperor of ethiopia who like
some people worship
and um i've actually met a couple of
those people now and of course they
eventually became ethiopian you know
today
christians so so yeah i i have a lot of
i just have a lot of questions about all
that
and then uh and then but also the
this this uh in the byzantine
apocalyptic tradition
ethiopia is very closely tied to the
myth of alexander
so i think that's going to be a really
natural segue into talking about
alexander and about all of these great
imitators of alexander
uh in the in the medieval universal
history so awesome and i think i also
want to talk about in our next
discussion on ethiopia i want to talk
about the traditions of ethiopia the
the way that we talk about the extreme
and to what extent
their traditions preserve extremes that
to us sometimes look so fringe that it's
hard to
it's hard to talk about them but it's
interesting to understand that this
accumulation of
extremes does seem to be the reason also
why they were able to preserve
texts that we have forgotten and that we
have kind of set aside so we can look at
all that
so one more teaser then yeah
the preservation and and i would say
that most like textual scholars don't
think this is true from like a
historical critical perspective okay
but the tradition is that the reason
that enoch and jubilees are preserved
is because of a group called the nine
saints yeah and the nine saints were
this these people who
uh at the calcidonian schism they came
out of the byzantine empire they went
into exile they went to ethiopia
and they brought with them all of this
learning that was not preserved
yeah anywhere else so those nine saints
man they are wild
bunch yeah if there's actually i i i
won't go too too much but there's one
who like
committed suicide to imitate christ like
crazy stuff that
we don't have in our traditions yeah
yeah and and and
don't necessarily want in our tradition
in some cases but
but it's there and it's yeah yeah yeah
yeah but it's
it's like i said it's good to understand
this as this kind of extreme and so
we'll talk about it next time
okay because we can just keep going now
next video is gonna be awesome
all right all right everybody so thank
you for your time i hope you're as
excited about ethiopia as we are
um and so you know and so so stay tuned
we're gonna
we're gonna keep going you know as long
as everybody's interested we're
definitely gonna keep going
and talking about this universal history
so thank you everybody for your
attention and we'll see
very soon bye as you know everything i'm
doing here is thanks to your help and
your support
there are many ways you can get involved
by commenting and sharing these ideas to
your friends
by getting involved in the symbolic
world facebook group or reddit
if you want to support this work
financially you can do it by purchasing
products with my designs on teespring
for example
for this podcast i created an exclusive
illustration based on
ethiopian crosses and ornamentation but
if you want to support it directly you
can also do it through my website or
patreon
supporters get an extra video a month
plus opportunities to ask questions and
participate
in exclusive discussion groups so thank
you everybody for your support and i'll
talk to you very soon